thing I've learned about lucasfilm and
it's true today as it was back in the
independent when I was in independent
Studio days they're very loyalty based
they're so they don't pay a lot but they
bring you back God they're like if you
ever ask them for a favor they're just
like what can we do you know oh can I
you know can I do some stuff for my
album at Skywalker Ranch like yeah we'll
set it up are you serious crazy stuff
Lucas home does this wonderful thing
where they're like oh you know Darth
Maul is uh in this Brisk iced tea
commercial I'm like oh what cool do you
think that they're like oh no no don't
worry the license basically says they
have to use who we say they use they're
using you so have fun making a bunch of
money on that you know I mean there